LIQUOR, THEY WERE BUYING IT FOR
DISINFECTING PURPOSES ONLY.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, GOVERNOR,
THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW WITH THAT THAT AS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT.
YOU DIDN’T GET HIT AS HARD AS
NEW YORK IT IS STILL TRICKY
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE GET TO
SPORTING EVENTS, CONCERTS,
RESTAURANTS IN PARTICULAR.
WE’VE GOT TO BE CAREFUL HOW WE
DO THIS, HOW ARE YOU THINKING
ABOUT DOING IT?
>> YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT IT IN
THE EXACT RIGHT WAY AND THAT IS
WE WANT TO OPEN.
TEXANS LOVE TO WORK AND THEY ARE
DYING TO GET BACK TO WORK AND WE
WANT THEM TO GET BACK TO WORK
BUT WE HAD TO DO SO IN A VERY
SAFE WAY SO THAT WE DON’T
REGENERATE THE SPREAD OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
BUT WE ARE WORKING ON STRATEGIES
AS WE SPEAK WITH MEDICAL
EXPERTS, BUSINESS LEADERS TO
FIND THE RIGHT STRATEGY SO WE
CAN UNLEASH OUR ECONOMY.
TEXAS WAS THE NUMBER ONE STATE
IN THE UNITED STATES FOR JOB
CREATION LAST YEAR LEADING IN
GROSS DOMESTIC PRODUCT, IT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR THE FUTURE OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
ECONOMICALLY.
AMERICA NEEDS TEXAS TO GET BACK
TO BUSINESS.
>> Sean: I THINK MOST STATES
CAN REOPEN EVEN SOONER THAN
LATER.
WE DON’T HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
MAY 1ST, BUT IT’S GOING TO BE
MORE CHALLENGING IN THE CITY
LIKE NEW YORK.
I THINK THERE’S A NEW NORMAL FOR
NEW YORK.
PROBABLY GOING TO WORK FROM HOME
FOR TODAY.
TAKING THE TEMPERATURE WITHOUT
TOUCHING ANYBODY.
IN CONTACT TRACING, WE CALL IT.
>> YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT ALL THE
RIGHT THINGS.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN OPEN WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME, WE’VE BEEN REDUCING
THE SPREAD OF THE CORONAVIRUS SO
WE NEED TO LEARN FROM THE
STRATEGIES ABOUT WHAT WORKS AND
ALLOW OTHER BUSINESSES TO DEPLOY
THOSE STRATEGIES WHILE WE ARE
ENSURING THAT WE CONTINUE TO
SLOW THE SPREAD OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, WE ARE